Speaker 1: Steve Doocy on fox and friends
yesterday morning had a cringing moment in
which they brought on a panel of republicans.
I guess these are and asked, you know, trump
now is saying defund the DOJ, defund the FBI.
Does anybody here think that that's a good
idea?
And not a single hand went up.
Take a look at this.
I love this stuff.
I really.
Speaker 4: Do.
Apparently today, Donald Trump has called
for America to defund the police, particularly
the FBI, the Department of Justice, because
the Democrats have weaponized law enforcement.
Right.
All right.
Who in this panel raise your hand?
Who thinks that's a good idea?
All right.
Nobody.
Speaker 1: So, listen, obviously, six people
aren't representative of the entire Republican
Party.
This is more about the optics of a total backfire
on TV, which, of course, triggers Trump even
further.
And this has the same vibe as when Fox News
hosted a town hall for Bernie Sanders, and
the audience applauded a lot of Bernie Sanders
ideas.
And it really didn't go the way that that
Fox wanted it to go from a narrative perspective.
So I think there's a couple of different things
here.
There are multiple passes that we often take
at this stuff right now.
There are plenty of Republican voters who
believe we shouldn't defund the police and
believe that Democrats want to defund the
police and don't believe that Republicans
want to defund the police.
And when presented with, hey, Trump's trying
to defund the police or he wants to defund
federal police, they got No, no, no, no, no,
no.
That's bad.
This is wave one.
But you have to understand that this is a
cult.
Now, whether these six people are part of
the cult or not, we don't actually know.
But much of the Trump cult eventually will
just change their tune.
Why?
Well, because this is one of the characteristics
of cults.
And we'll talk about some of the other characteristics
later today.
One of the characteristics of cults is consistency.
Doesn't matter.
The consistency of the message that you believe
from your cult leader doesn't matter.
It can change overnight and you simply change
your thinking and the cult leader is justified
if they move on to yes, support local police.
But federal police has been weaponized as
a political tool against Republicans only.
So the FBI and the DOJ must be defunded.
They will just adjust their view.
The double standard doesn't matter.
The about face doesn't matter.
And this is one of the characteristics of
cults.
You hear a from the from the Dear Leader and
you follow it.
And the next day the leader says nowaday.
And you say, Oh, we're following that.
And their word is perfect and their word is
divine, almost like a pseudo deity.
So, yeah, good for these six people, I guess.
I mean, they they don't want to defund the
police for now, but a large number of Trump
supporters have already come around to the
side, and many more probably will as well.
All of the clips that I played for you here
you can find not only on our YouTube channel
but also on our Instagram by searching for
David Pakman show and increasingly popular
more than 30 million views last month on Tik
Tok alone.
If you're into the Tik tok, you can find us
there at David Pakman.
So we'll take a quick break and be back with
much more.